haven't made their way out of the site  this could be dangerous  there it is oh no he can't get the kill  he's gotta fall back like get rights  ready - big kills he's only got one left  inside of the site and now he knows it  very good left in the 1v1 on the goods  fit fit nice oh my god sir time in  Kerrigan going back in  good point said I guess I stepped away  direction but there's gonna be a lot  more steps on what might be affected but  there's only Todd coach is completely of  this rate scale advanced form P - no  he's not he's spitting it out this on a  slope  he's got for killin see gotta he has to  go for the a series got to get home for  coming his way so every single position  checks every angle is protective forever  would you protect Jaco to take a fight  here to play see you see every day  in their favor  as you like